We're going to do a predator prey cycles.
We're going to do rabbits eating foxes, and we're going to try and use maths,
right?
And what's it going to eat boxes? We're not going to do well.
We are doing foxes, eating rabbits.
Can we mathematically model and explain and predict the changes in the
population, numbers of the interaction between a predator. In this case,
a Fox eating the prey, a rabbit, you are going to represent our price.
Okay.
We tend to use UNV a lot in math.
We can't use PE because it's prey and predator.
So you is going to be the rabbit, the prey, here we go.
Attempt to draw a rabbit, some ears, a leg. Do they have whiskers? All right.
There's a row. I think that's a pretty good rabbit. Okay.
And then V is going to represent our Fox,
got like a big tail of body paint years and they could point you note. Okay.
So Fox, we have a rabbit and a Fox,
and we want to try and write down at equations that are going to explain the
interaction between them. You know, the rabbits will,
will keep growing and populating, but as they do,
there's more food for the foxes.
So the foxes might start to grow and then there's too many foxes.
So there's like a complicated interaction between the two.
And that's sort of ultimately what leads to this really nice predator-prey
dynamics in, in the model.
We want to try and figure out the change in the population of the prey
over time. So that means writing down a derivative.
So it's the change in the population, Stu with respect to time,
if we have more rabbits, we expect that, you know,
they're going to repopulate. This is, you know, it's, it's,
it's a actual metaphor or idiom or whatever.
Is there about like rabbits?
So I'm going to breed like rabbits relate.
Robbins. That was the word I was thinking of. So the girls,
so we've got to breed like rabbits. If we have more rabbits,
this is going to grow. Population gets bigger. We get more rabbits. The.
More rabbits you have, the more of it you get.
Exactly the change in the population will also be affected by the foxes.
And that's going to be a decrease. If there's more foxes to eat the rabbits,
they will go down.
So that's going to be a minus because it depends on both Fox number and rabbit
number. It's going to be a U times a week. So that sort of shows.
So this is the rabbits growing by themselves.
And then this is being eaten by the foxes so they can put hair reproduction or
this term. And then this is what we would call the predation term.
So are rabbits being eaten by foxes. Now,
if we want to write down on the same for the foxes,
so we're going to start with the rate of change of the,
the predator population over time. Now the Fox is,
will grow when there's more food,
because they're not denying them prolific at breeding,
we're going to put in a constant, let's just call it alpha.
And this is going to be UV.
And this is a plus cause it's going to increase the Fox population.
So more food available.
And then now what you're going to see is the negative bets that causes the
Fox population to decrease is when there are too many foxes.
Because if there are loads of says,
there's a lot of competition for catching and eating the rabbits.
Whereas the rabbits don't face that problem.
Cause we're assuming there's always enough left.
Yes, whatever rabbits.
I used to feed my rabbit lettuce on the war. Okay. All right,
grass. So whatever it is, the rabbits eat.
So there's going to be, we're going to show you those lots of it.
So they're just going to keep growing. But the Fox is,
are going to decrease when there's more foxes because there's more competition
to eat those rabbits. So this is going to be minus alpha times V.
Now the alpha is just a constant, the same app or are they, it's the same.
It's the same alpha.
So I've kind of skipped over a step because what we've actually done is if you
wrote out the full model,
you'd have different constants on each of the four terms. And then you do, um,
the classic applied maths track of non dimensionalize,
everything to get rid of all of these constants.
So I've just skipped over that and all,
all that you end up with when you do that and you can work through this,
it's you just get the one constant, which is the same thing.
This is now going to be our model. So this bit here is competition.
So we've got the rabbits.
They grow because they reproduce and they go down because there's more foxes.
The Fox is there's more food available.
So they increase with the rabbit population and they decrease with their own
population because of competition. So now we have a set of equations.
Do you buy your tea?
It depends on you and V and DV here depends on you in V.
So this is what makes them, what we call a coupled set of equations,
because you can't just solve this one because you need to know V but to get
veer, you have to solve this one and you need to know you.
So this is like the sort of complex dynamics between the predator prey,
because they are so interdependent.
I want another normally to solve differential equation, you do and integral.
You use some, you know, tricks of the trade,
but in the practice of pre interaction in math, biology,
you just draw lots of really nice pictures and it's super cool.
So that's what we're going to do and try and draw out.
What does this look like in what we call the phase plan are two axes.
Now there are a few things we can draw straight away here.
So the only information we have to,
to construct our phase plane is going to be these two equations.
So a good starting point is think about what happens on the two axes.
So if we plug in a V being zero is going to be our starting point.
So V being zero is the UXs access here.
So we plugged that in that disappears.
So that tells us that the change in U is equal to the value of you.
So if I'm, let's say here at some positive number of U V via zero,
so that term disappears.
And now I've got the change in the population is equal to a positive number
because I'm a positive number. So the change is positive means it's increasing.
So if I'm here, I have to be going that way. There's nothing else I can do.
I'm just going to keep going along here, which makes complete sense.
There are zero predators. So if you're a rabbit,
you're just breeding all day long and growing and growing and growing your
population. Similarly along this one, we have that. You is that right?
So we have no prey. Now we'll come at this from the biology angle,
we've got no prey. And we have some number of predators, some number of foxes.
They're a bit screwed. Let's be honest. I've got nothing to eat.
They can't go and eat that letter.
So they're going to decrease and you're going to go down like that.
And you get the same year equations. Cause you take this plugin. You equals not,
you get rid of that term and you've got the change in V equal to something
negative. So you're going down.
So now we actually want to go back to our equations and think about things that
we call a steady States.
So this is a particular population number where
both the prey and the predator, the rabbit, and the Fox are happy.
It sticks at a constant number. There's no change. Once you get to this point,
this particular number of rabbits and corresponding number of foxes.
Once you get there, everyone's just happy and there's no change.
We call this a steady state.
And so what that means mathematically in this equation is that you will be equal
to some constant number. And so if you, as constant,
it doesn't change with time because it's constant.
That's the sort of definition of constant.
So that term goes so to find which values of you,
our population is happy at, we just solve this equal to zero.
So we've got to solve you. Minus UV equals naught.
We need to find values of U and V, which will satisfy this equation.
So the first one would be, you can be zero, then that works.
And then the second one you could also have. Few is not zero.
Then if V was equal to one,
you'd have you minus you now for a proper steady state.
Remember we needed both populations to be happy. So they sort of,
that's why it's called a steady state.
They reached this point and they just sit there and just Bob along,
without changing. So if this one doesn't change, we've got the same idea here.
This is alpha times V times you minus one must be zero.
So if you as not, that was option one, then that's not.
Then the only way for that to be zero is for V to be zero because the U term has
vanished. So if you is not the is not, and that is warm, steady state.
And if V is one, that's a one.
So you has to be one to make this Sarah now. So you as one.
So these are only two possible steady States.
These are the two values where our population is happy.
So now we can go back to our phase plane.
So we have one of them here and now this makes complete sense for no
predators or no prey to be a happy place for the population.
There's nothing there. So it ain't going to change. There's nothing that can be,
you know, they can't reproduce, they can't kill each other.
It's just ain't happening.
It's just so nice when you do the maths and you get this answer like, Oh yeah,
the population is happy when there's nothing.
And then you think about it as you said, Oh yeah, there's nothing there. Great.
That's exactly what we expect to really good sanity check where you're doing the
right thing and your math. That's correct.
So we can either have that and they'll happily sit there.
But then what we can also have is one and one,
what you can now do with this particular steady state is something called a
stability analysis. This is a bit advanced, um,
sort of a dynamics or mechanics type thing. Um,
and what we can work out is we can work out the behavior around this particular
point. It turns out that in this situation,
you get something which is called a center, uh,
near this point of the population,
the population pathways look like this.
So you do this stability analysis and it tells you that these things go round in
circles.
Now we can actually complete the rest of our phase planning because the way the
phase plane works is these arrows tell you how the population behaves
when you start to just a certain number. So we said here,
if I start with this number of predators, the faceplate and says,
I'm just going to decrease in, die out,
which makes complete biological sense because there is zero prey here.
So they all just die. And similarly,
if I start here where there are no predators,
I'm just going to increase forever. Now we've,
we've done our fancy stability analysis to say that near this point,
they sort of go round in circles,
but we don't yet know which way around they go.
And what we have to do to fill that in is look at the rest of the face plate,
because there's a really important rule about phase planes that your
trajectories, these pathways you're drawing,
they can never cross and all of the directions sort of follow.
It's like a flow. So you have water going this way and water going this way.
It wouldn't make sense to be sort of going like that.
It would be going against the flow.
Each pathway influences the pathway next to it.
So what's actually happening here is you've got really big cycles looking,
something like this, going all the way around this particular point,
this one, one steady state situation. And so this is all consistent.
Everything fits all of these directions work.
Yeah, I see what you mean. It feels intuitively right up the top there,
the rabbits are going the wrong way.
Think about what's happening here. So they're going opposite to down here,
but they've crossed through this sort of threshold, that magical pole,
magical stability point up that bit where the population's happy. So,
so what's actually happening up here is if you sort of approximately look at the
numbers, your prayers on around one,
and your predator is like way above that. So there's,
there's a lot of predators per rabbit.
So that's why it kind of makes sense for the rabbits to start coming down again,
because you've got more proud. You've got a surplus of predators.
So as a rabbit, you know,
you've not just got one person after you've got like several, so we can now,
now we've got the space plane.
What we do is we can pick a point on here and then follow the arrows.
And that will tell us how the population of the rabbits and the foxes will
change in relation to one another. Now that we've got the phase plane.
So even though we haven't solved any equations,
we've just turned our equations into a picture and the picture then gives us the
answer.
So we now think about starting at a certain point and what will happen to the
rabbits and the foxes. Let's see, we start here.
So this is going to be population number,
and this is going to be time because this is ultimately what the real question
was at the start. We want to know, how did their populations change.
Over time? Population of rabbits or foxes.
Were going to be rabbits first, as you move anywhere on this diagram,
both of them change. Cause you're in your to coordinate system. We start here,
we're at about one, right? So it doesn't really matter.
Let's just call that our starting point at the beginning. Now what's happening.
We are increasing, increasing, increasing, increasing,
just in thinking about what's happening to you. I pray.
So we increase and then we get to some maximum value of you.
And then we start to come back down and we go all the way down past where we
were just looking at the rabbits.
And then we go below where we were hit a minimum.
And then we come back to this point, okay. Probably looks quite familiar.
So it's some kind of oscillation. It's like a cause or a sign or something.
Some kind of wave like behavior in the rabbit population.
And then we're going to just continue to go round and round this cause we can't
cross. We can't leave. It's sort of.
It goes around in a circles. So we just continue to do this. So this.
Is the prey, the rabbits, there you go, rabbits.
Now the Fox is so at our starting point, the Fox is, are below one.
It doesn't really matter where,
but they're below this value C to start down here. As we move around,
they slowly.
Increase very slowly increase.
Then they increase a bit faster. They slowly increase.
Then they come around and we get to a maximum all the way up here.
And then they come back down to, it turns out approximately this minimum point.
So we've got a similar behavior that we saw with the rabbits,
except when the rabbits started here,
which is sort of halfway between the maximum and the foxes are starting
approximately at their minimum value. So they have the same.
[Inaudible] so this is the predator.
Yes. A little teeth. I don't know if that's a Fox
Fox rabbit. As we go around this particular loop,
the rabbits start to increase and increase and increase.
And as the rabbits are increasing, there's quite a lot of food.
So the Fox says like, Oh, this is great.
There's going to be more and more foxes. Cause there's lots to eat. So that's,
there's plentiful food supply.
They're going to reproduce lots and have lots of kids or whatever.
Little baby foxes are called and then they're going to start to increase.
But then as there's more foxes,
the rabbits have a lot of predators after them.
So now the rabbits are scared for their lives and the rabbits are getting killed
a lot. So the rabbit start to go down, but the Fox is still increasing,
but now the rabbits have gone down. There's loads of foxes.
There's not many rabbits. The foxes are going to die out.
They've got a food shortage. Now they had a food surplus down here.
Now they've got a food shortage. So down here there's more rabbits and foxes.
And then at this critical point, there's now more.
Then there are rabbits, even when the rabbits started falling for a while,
it was still good times. Yeah.
It was. It's like a lag it's lagging a little bit behind.
So they're both doing this oscillation of up and down,
but this is the Fox just legs a little bit behind the rabbit. Because until,
you know, if you imagine it's one rabbit per one Fox,
until you cross through that, it's always for the foxes.
There's always a surplus of food. There's more food than they need.
So they're just going to keep me produce it. And then, you know,
perhaps it's due to, uh,
the sort of gestation time or something for that for the baby to be born,
but then it sort of it lags behind a bit.
And then all of a sudden the rabbits have gone down because there's too many
foxes and then the foxes see them.
The client, and you've drawn these on this graph. There,
there are similar sizes, but presumably the absolute numbers could be different.
It could be a billion rabbits to thousands.
Absolutely.
So that's the reason we've done the non dimensionalization right at the very
beginning. So they're sort of happy place is one,
one that doesn't mean one rabbit and one Fox that sort of means the one hair
is like the perfect number of rabbits. And this is the perfect number of foxes.
We've sort of scaled out in that non dimensionalization.
So I've got rid of the units.
I would imagine that would need quite a lot of rabbits to sustain a single Fox,
the non dimensionalization. It maintains the really important stuff.
So it tells you that you have this oscillation, this predator prey cycle,
it tells you that it's going to happen,
but it doesn't tell you the exact numbers,
but like from a sort of population dynamics idea,
you don't really care too much about the exact numbers.
You just want to know that there's going to be peaks and troughs in each of the
populations. And you can look at actual data for any pretty much any predator,
prey situation in nature. You see exactly this, you have the,
the boom in the prey followed by a boom in the predator and then
the decrease exactly in the setup.
And it all just follows from sort of those simple equations we wrote down at the
very beginning and then drawing a pretty picture of the face plane,
just to emphasize the level of favoritism with these equations,
the full Maria Stokes equations as written down on a piece of paper,
hang on which way round though, we we're talking this area.
So those should be exactly the ones that are written down the little.
Do I go the little go and the big.
That's right? Yeah.
And just zigzagging back and forth sort of living around zero,
but in a really complicated way. And so the thought was that okay,